hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well when do you have
to make choices
yes to choose not to make a choice as in
a some respect to choose something is to
choose to let something else call shots
right there's a band Rush and actually
like work that into their song called
free will right and they were actually
just taking stuff right from start you
always choose drive your life so choice
is let's say let's get more determined
when do you actually have to make
choices that that matter to you it's
always in some sort of situation right
yeah
okay
so there's some sort of good some sort
of value that motivate to do you have to
choose when there's only one possibility
then there's two possibilities all right
it's totally out of your hands that it's
gonna go the way it's gonna go there's
no choice so anytime that there is a
choice involved there's different
directions that might be just - it's a
beautiful function 40 minutes we're
saying well I believe if I want like one
possibility we could do it you know I
think yeah if there's if there's one
thing that you could do you could also
would not do it right or you can do it
half way or you know that would be a
different choice actually
Sartre perspective now how do you
actually decide what to do this goes to
that question that I asked earlier about
what resources do you have for moral
decision-making what are some of the
resources that you have relied on in
your life not have you been character
and Aristotle right
examples of parents older family members
there might be might expand that to
people in certain social roles you know
in our society religion for a lot of
people provides a pretty coherent system
for for figuring these sorts of things
out sometimes there's no clear
prescriptions don't do this or have to
do this what else the principles that
don't steal things now you could have
gotten that from parents you could have
gotten that from the religious ores
commandment against stealing a lot of
other places where it says don't steal
dig around the odds in your society yeah
yeah if the laws are set up well they're
supposed to actually make better people
off of us or at least keep us from
becoming really bad there's always so
much you can do with it Martin Luther
King got this famous statement where he
says something along the lines of the
law did not make a man love me but it
can sure keep them from killing and
that's not nothing that's something
worth the law do so yeah now why do
these men they make us choose the things
that we do they are the infallible
guides some of the people were to look
at this semester would say yeah in some
cases they could be start doesn't think
they are this is he thinks that it
ultimately comes down to your choice so
think about this example that he has
the young man maybe you had a little bit
of trouble relating to it because it's
such a different situation but I think
you've been in some difficult violence
yourself right this young man is in
occupied France the Nazis have come in
and taken over we're doing horrible
things all over the people
this guy really loves his mom and he is
staying with her she's not doing too
well and he's the one who's there to
take care of her and she she's really
attached so if he leaves it's almost
like giving her a death sentence
right on the other hand the Nazis are
occupying his country and they are
pretty bad and other they're doing
horrible things to people visibly on the
streets he has a chance to go do
something about that you could join the
resistance and you know maybe you end up
in the Free French forces come back to
liberate France these are both good
things to do aren't they and this young
man comes according to Sartre
he may have made this other young man
comes to circuses what should I do
Sartre says yeah this is this is really
a problem what would you rely on to make
that sort of choice it says well if you
consult the Christian religion it
doesn't actually tell you which thing we
should attack I mean you could probably
find depending on how you're
interpreting you know your religion
maybe it's a matter of finding the right
Bible verses have you ever like gone
through and then you can find Bible
verses seemingly for and seemingly
against if you choose one Authority you
might get one answer is another
Authority might get another answer it's
not the sort of thing that's really easy
to figure out what about if you say well
you know Christianity is all about love
so I do the love of thing well is that
to stay with your mom or is that to love
the other people in your country which
one takes priority
Sartre says the only thing that can
decide that is your choice nothing else
can tell you what what the right thing
to do is what if you consulted a book
about this you read contravene Aristotle
John Stuart Mill there are definitely
some things where they disagree
we're gonna look at that this semester
well who's making you follow Kant's
guidelines or Aristotle's bad ones you
write your choice again if you go with
context that a mil or you go with say
John Paul Sartre instead of eras level
you're the one making that choice again
and it doesn't do you any good to say
well Kant's right - that's why I'm going
with them because according to Sartre
the reason why Conte is right is because
you're choosing for him to be right
about ethics are there any other things
that you could examine well you know
examples are kind of tough to use to
erect Atticus you never quite sure
exactly what this person would do in
this novel circumstance not not appear
that I actually hold myself this is what
services I think
there's like feelings
do you ever rely on your feelings for
making moral decisions I know I did you
guys once how many of you ever like have
done something and then you felt what we
called kings of conscious and conscience
did something bad okay maybe you can
rely on that right or do you ever feel
affection or evolved towards people that
makes you want to do the right thing by
them even though you don't really feel
like doing the right thing is that
sometimes guide you into figuring
everything else now Sartre would say
you're responsible for that emotion you
choose to follow that for you
so you're juicing someone else
well no they aren't your choice you're
thinking about it's like a whole table
full of I get up the same all right you
got your [ __ ] plates and your Aristotle
play it's a mirror Bible verse plates
mom and dad plates unconscious plates
and you walk through and they're all
pretty attractive well they probably
always you know fill you up unless it
turns out you have allergies to some of
these these things but you're the one
who actually gets to pick them and so
maybe today it's it's all aerosol and
you're gonna go with him you're the one
who chose that and there's no there's no
thing coercing that choice making you to
do that you could say well Aristotle
made me choose Aristotle it's hard to
say that's completely circular that
bottled it's you I like Aristotle will
you choose to make liking the criterion
by which you settle these these things
so start will say ultimately it's all up
to our individual choice and now does
that choice have any criterion outside
of itself no as a matter of fact he says
you make things good by deciding for
them to be the good so all of you think
about this as an example you're all here
in a college classroom you could be in a
lot of other places right you could have
joined the military
you're working right now you could be a
criminal you could just be like sitting
at home somebody's basement taking the
easy but you chose to come here and
apply yourself and you've made it
through you know two years in two and a
half years we were seniors three years
you put in all this work you decided
that that was a fundamental good for you
you may have had parents telling you oh
you have to go to school you may have
had people threatening those
consequences if you don't go to school
then you're gonna be you know a hard
time in the workplace but obviously that
doesn't compel everybody because there's
some people that are just sitting in a
couch in the basement watching TV right
now who are your age you aren't holding
a job aren't making anything of
themselves and they've been able to make
that choice
so clearly those consequences by
themselves don't necessarily make people
do anything it's you choosing to be what
you're going to be you making of
yourself a project you determining again
what your essence is going to be and
start this we're not actually going to
get into this very deeply Sartre says
that when you do that you're not just
deciding for yourself you're deciding
what human being I'm not sure that he
can actually get get away with that I
think that maybe once you pull the
bottom out that's all a matter of
individual choice and there's no
criteria for that choice there may be
some some difficulties in justifying
that a weekly to talk about that some
small time